HOPEFULLY IN THE SENATE.
THE CHOICE IS YOURS.
THE STAKES, THEY COULDN'T BE
HIGHER.
JOINING US NOW IS HOUSE MINORITY
LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY.
CONGRESSMAN, WELCOME BACK.
GLAD YOU ARE WITH US.
I WAS THE MC THE NIGHT
NEWT GINGRICH BECAME SPEAKER.
THE FIRST TIME IN 40 YEARS
REPUBLICANS TOOK CONTROL OF THE
HOUSE.
THEY CAPTAIN FILLED THEIR
PROMISE.
THEY HAD A CONTRACT WITH
AMERICA.
YOURS ARE COMMITMENTS TO
I HAVE URGED REPUBLICANS TO DO
THIS, I'M GLAD YOU'RE DOING
THIS.
THERE IS A VERY STRONG COMPONENT
OF ACCOUNTABILITY HERE, ALL
MEMBERS THAT WILL RUN ON THESE
COMMITMENTS THEY ARE PLEDGING TO
VOTERS THAT ARE GOING TO KEEP
THEM.
CORRECT?
>> CORRECT.
I WANTED TO ROLLOUT IN
WASHINGTON COUNTY, PENNSYLVANIA.
THE COMMITMENT TO AMERICA IS
ABOUT YOU, AMERICA, NOT
WASHINGTON.
WHAT WE HAVE IS A PLAN FOR NEW
DIRECTION.
WE SPENT THE YEAR AND A HALF,
ALL THE REPUBLICAN MEMBERS IN
CONGRESS ON DIFFERENT
TASK FORCES GOING OUT TO LISTEN
TO THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
IF YOU WATCH THE ROLLOUT TODAY,
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE DID HERE.
WE DIDN'T GET UP AND JUST TALK
TO YOU.
WE TOOK QUESTIONS FROM THE
AUDIENCE.
HOW CAN WE MAKE THIS ECONOMY
STRONG?
HOW CAN WE LOWER OUR GASOLINE
PRICE?
HOW CAN WE AFFORD TO STOP
INFLATION?
A NATION THAT IS SAFE.
200,000 NEW POLICE OFFICERS
MAKING SURE D.A.'S AND
PROSECUTORS ARE UPHOLDING THE
LAW.
A FUTURE BUILT ON FREEDOM.
YOUR VOTE PARENTS
BILL OF RIGHTS, SR. KIDS
EDUCATION, QUESTION, SHE CALLED
HERSELF A MAMA BEAR.
SHE HAD GONE TO THE SCHOOL BOARD
MEETING BECAUSE HER POOR
DAUGHTER WAS GETTING LEFT BEHIND
AND SHE GETS CALLED A TERRORIST.
WE WANT YOU TO HAVE A SAY.
HOW DO WE HOLD THIS GOVERNMENT
ACCOUNTABLE?
NO CHECK AND BALANCE.
WE WILL BE ABLE TO BRING IN.
WE HAVE A PLAN.
THE PRESIDENT ATTACKED IT LAST
NIGHT.
HE WANTS TO ATTACK IT BECAUSE
MUCH OF HIS POLICIES.
THIS PROBLEM AND HE IS NO PLAN
BUT WE DO.
THAT'S OUR COMMITMENT TO YOU.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT HAS TO
ATTACK.
THERE IS NO POLICY SUCCESS THAT
THEY CAN POINT TO.
THE WORST INFLATION IN 40 YEARS,
HIGHEST GAS PRICES WE'VE EVER
PAID.
A RECORD OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO.
OVER 2 MILLION ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS AND WE KNOW ABOUT THE
COUNTRY.
ONE FOREIGN POLICY DISASTER
AFTER ANOTHER.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, THIS
ELECTION, WHAT ARE WE, 47 DAYS
AWAY?
46 DAYS AWAY.
THIS IS CRITICAL.
SO MUCH OF THIS DEPENDS ON THE
ECONOMY AND SO MUCH OF IT IS
SELF-INFLICTED.
GO BACK TO THE TRUMP POLICIES ON
THE BORDER, YOU PROMISED TO DO
THAT.
THEY WILL WORK.
THEY'VE BEEN PROVEN TO WORK.
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE.
THAT WILL NOT ONLY CREATE HIGH
PAYING CAREER JOBS.
GOOD FOR NATIONAL SECURITY.
IT WILL LOWER THE PRICE OF THE
PUMP AND LOWER THE PRICE OF
EVERY ITEM IN EVERY STORE AND
LOWER THE INFLATION.
ONE OF THE ABANDONED THE SINGLE
BEST MOST INDEPENDENT THING THAT
OUR ECONOMY NEEDS, THE LIFEBLOOD
OF OUR ECONOMY, ENERGY.
WHY DO THEY STOP DOMESTIC
PRODUCTION.
>> ON THE VERY FIRST DAY THEY
WENT AFTER ALL THE ENERGY
COMPANIES TELLING THEM TO
PRODUCE LESS.
THAT MAKES US DEPENDENT ON OTHER
COUNTRIES.
WHY ARE WE GOING TO BE
DEPENDENT?
WE ARE GOING TO BE ENERGY
INDEPENDENT WHICH CREATES
LUBRICANT JOBS, LURES INFLATION,
KEEPS MORE OF YOUR MONEY IN YOUR
POCKET.
THE OTHER THING IS IT MAKES THE
WORLD SAFER.
AMERICA ENERGY INDEPENDENCE,
ALSO AMERICAN NATURAL GAS IS 40%
CLEANER THAN RUSSIAN NATURAL GAS
SO WHY DON'T WE SELL OUR NATURAL
GAS TO EUROPE SO THEY ARE NOT
BEHOLDEN TO PUTIN AND OTHERS.
STOP THE FENTANYL FROM COMING
ACROSS AND KILLING OUR CHILDREN.
>> Sean: FOUR BIG ITEMS WITH
SOME ITEMS IN THEM.
THE ECONOMY THAT INCLUDES ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE, FIGHTING
INFLATION, STRENGTHENING THE
SUPPLY CHAIN.
SAFETY AND SECURITY OF OUR
BORDER EVERY TOWN IN EVERY CITY.
GET RID OF THESE INSANE NO BAIL
LAWS.
REFUND THE POLICE, NOT DEFUND
THE POLICE.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE FUTURE BUILT
ON FREEDOM.
THAT STARTS WITH EDUCATION.
BY THAT, I KNOW YOU MEAN
READING, WRITING, MATH, SCIENCE,
HISTORY, COMPUTERS, NOT WOKE
THIS AND WOKE THAT.
AND CRT.
>> WE ENSURE FAIRNESS.
ONLY WOMEN COMPETE IN WOMEN'S
SPORTS.
WE GIVE YOU A PARENTS
BILL OF RIGHTS.
WE WANT EDUCATION SYSTEM FOCUSED
ON CHILDREN, TEACHING THEM TO
DREAM BIG.
WE HAVE A PLAN TO CATCH OUR
CHILDREN UP FOR THE LOST
LEARNING THAT HAPPENED IN THE
PANDEMIC.
DEMOCRATS HAVE NO PLAN.
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE.
WE SHOULD HAVE AN ELECTION BASED
UPON IDEAS.
WE HAVE A NEW PLAN.
COMMITMENT TO AMERICA.
THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO ATTACK
IT, LET HIM ATTACK IT.
I CHALLENGE HIM TO A DEBATE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT HIS POLICIES
AND WHAT THE FUTURE CAN BE WITH
THIS COMMITMENT AND I PROMISE
YOU IT'S NOT ABOUT REPUBLICANS.
THIS IS ABOUT OUR COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHY I NEED EVERYONE WHO
IS LISTED TO JOIN WITH US.
GO TO TakeTheHouse.com.
NANCY PELOSI SAYS SHE'S GOING TO
WIN SEATS.
THE DCCC SAYS THEY ARE GOING TO
WIN VACCINES.
NO ONE GIVES YOU MAJORITY BUT
THIS IS A FIGHT FOR OUR NATION.
YOU WANT SOME ECONOMY THAT IS
STRONG, SAFE, IF YOU WANT TO
FUTURE BUILT ON FREEDOM AND IF
YOU WANT TO HAVE SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY TO YOUR
GOVERNMENT, THIS IS WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN.
SEAN, I PROMISE YOU THIS.
ON THE VERY FIRST DAY, OUR VERY
FIRST BILL IS GOING TO REPEAL
87,000 IRS AGENTS BECAUSE WE
WORK FOR YOU AND IT'S NOT THE
OTHER WAY AROUND.
>> Sean: HOUSE MINORITY LEADER
KEVIN McCARTHY, WE WISH YOU
LUCK.
THANK YOU.
WE'LL BE TALKING TO A LOT OF THE
CA